c'est une nouvelle saison culturelle
pleine de promesse forte de ses dix-sept
mille visiteurs l'an dernier la
commanderie s'est préparé pour une
programmation encore plus complète pour
le lancement les visiteurs ont pu
découvrir des prestations de danse en
plein air des expositions photos ou
encore des ateliers du son au tour du
theremin c'est comme beaucoup
d'instruments à cordes le violon etc
il ya une main qui se charge de
l'émission du sont donc le volume du son
l'intensité sonore et une main qui se
chargent la hauteur donc typiquement
c'est la main gauche d'un violoniste ou
d'un violoncelliste là chez nous c'est
la main droite l'antenne verticale du
thérémine et est donc le but c'est
évidemment d'avoir une très bonne
coordination entre dès demain pour que
les notes soient clairement séparés et
expressive la première saison à la
commanderie tourné en grande partie
autour de la culture
cette année ce lieu va s'ouvrir
également à d'autres perspectives
la culture reste quand même le socle ou
aujourd'hui on doit être
pluridisciplinaire on doit une
multiplicité de stimuli est capable
d'accompagner les gens l'ailé les ouvrir
sur sur ce monde très très multiples
donc voilà c'est le but bien entendu au
travers de 50 entre la commanderie
nous notre objectif c'est que ce soit un
lieu de vie pas seulement estampillé
culture mais que les gens aient envie
d'y venir
envie de découvrir et c'est pour ça que
nous avons une programmation bien
évidemment culturelle dans les quatre
missions mais aussi de projets tels que
noël décalé au cinéma de plein air ou
voilà que nous tentons de mettre en
place pour que tout le monde puisse
s'approprier la commanderie
à l'occasion des journées du patrimoine
de nombreuses activités sont à retrouver
la commanderie proposera notamment un
jeu de piste samedi 21 et dimanche 22
septembre